the stereotype older people are less
productive and no longer capable of
holding down a job but that's simply not
true more and more people are working
beyond retirement age in 2005 that
applied to 6.5 percent of over 65s in
germany by 2014 that number had climbed
to 14.5 percent putting Germany ahead of
Italy in the UK the percentage is even
higher and in Estonia greater still what
about the adage you can't teach an old
dog new tricks well that's wrong too
after roughly thirty four thousand
people auditing courses at German
universities almost half for over 60
it's true that cognitive loss does occur
as people age but in many seniors these
changes are coming later and later and
what about mobility
while in 1985 only 1 in 10 75 to 79
year-olds had a driver's license
nowadays up to half of them still get
behind the wheel
[Music]
and seniors are an increasingly
important market for the tourism
industry cultural and educational tours
are more popular with over 65s
than beach holidays but don't older
people have to pinch their pennies in
Germany one in six elderly people is
currently at risk of poverty and in the
future this figure could rise to one in
five but the fact is seniors have a
higher average disposable income than
any other age group all told their total
spending power climbed over the past
decade to 375 billion euros one in every
three euros is spent by a senior
[Music]